alors c'est yvan attal comment ça va y
vend mais non je suis pas en pleine
émission je suis chez moi je suis rentré
là comment ça va la l'émission et j'ai
dit depuis longtemps bien sûr que tu
crois dès que vous êtes parti on
arrêtait très 101 est attendu à 5 euros
à chabal maintien et son sosie de sydney
pollack formidable
comment ça va ça s'est bien passé
j'étais content oui yvan je t'écoute il
dit j'aurais dû rester c'est tout vivant
tu peux revenir revient pour le blind
test
aucun changement n'est à 100 je crois
que le musée de revenir dans le blayais
sinon cela est ridicule
tout le monde va croire parce que tu as
peur de faire des plans shopping test je
ne sais quoi dans une demi heure laurent
whale blind test dans une demi heure
c'est yvan wimbée qui reviennent bas il
revient on t'attend quoi boulogne ici
pour vous mais tu t'en fous elle n'est
pas apparue une charlotte que tu t'en
fous tu fais ce que tu veux faire avec
toi un brevet transforme à sa porte toi
bien éventuelles